Here's a question for you.
Is using proper grammar important?
The answer is yes and no.
In fact,
the correct answer is probably,
it depends. Let me explain.
In linguistics,
grammar is generally defined,
has a knowledge of the system of rules
implicit in a language that exists in the
mind of a speaker, which includes rules
for phonology, morphology, syntax,
and semantics.
But when we try to take that knowledge
out of the mine of the speaker and write
it down, one is produce can
be described in three ways.
Descriptive grinders attempt to describe
the rules that exist in the minds of
the speakers and do not attempt
to tell you how you should speak.
Prescriptive grammars attempt to prescribe
certain rules of grammar and do tell
you how you should speak.
Teaching grammars are generally used in
schools and are used to teach students a
standard dialect of the language,
whether or not their native
speakers of that language. Today,
we're mainly going to talk about
prescriptive grammars for the sake of this
study,
let's look at the word important in two
different ways as we attempt to answer
the following questions.
One is using proper grammar important
as it relates to the purpose of language
that is done using proper grammar.
Help us to exchange ideas between
two groups of people and if so,
can using improper grammar
be equally as successful too?
Is using proper grammar
socially important?
That is is using proper grammar
important to us as a society?
Whether or not it aids in communication?
If so,
should it be important first
or we're not prescriptive.
This grammar prescriptive,
this,
I'm more concerned about the
social importance of grammar.
They're not interested in whether
a rule of grammar helps or hinders
communication.
They're more interested in whether or
not their language and the language of
others is correct.
That it's held to the highest standard
even when many times that standard is
based on an arbitrary set of rules and
governed by the pretentious elites of
society.
In other words,
grammar is important to them just because
they see everything as right or wrong.
If it was correct or standard grammar,
you're seen as better than others,
not necessarily because you
communicate more clearly,
but because you do
things in the proper way.
If you use bad or substitute or grammar,
you're seen as wrong.
Whether or not you communicated
your idea clearly to the other party
prescriptive.
This can include those who
consider themselves grammar
Nazis who are constantly
correcting the grammar and pronunciation
of those around them who cringe when
they hear someone misuse who and Kuhn.
They are those who cry out against the
decay of grammar and the corruption of
the English language.
Interestingly enough,
crying out against the corruption of
language is not at all a new invention.
It's been going on for centuries.
One might even assume it's been going on
since the beginning of humankind itself
over 250 years ago.
Bishop Robert Loud of thing,
grammar prescriptive this of the 18th
century wrote down his series of arbitrary
rules designed to prescribe how both of
the upperclass should speak is from that
we get sucked rules as two negatives
make a positive and one was never end the
sentence with a preposition besides
being based on his personal preferences.
The other problem with many of his rules
is that there were based on the grammar
of Latin and made little
real sense in English,
Winston Churchill even famously mocked
that never end a sentence with a
preposition role by saying this is the
sort of nonsense up with which I will not
put what Louth and many other grammar
prescriptive is failed to realize is that
languages are constantly changing and
that language change or for that matter,
language variation does not equate with
language corruption. So while today,
some idealized the English of yesterday,
they should keep in mind that many
people who spoke the English of yesterday
still found fault in it.
The truth is English is no better
or worse than it used to be.
It's just different.
So is using proper grammar important as
it relates to the purpose of language?
Yes and no.
Many of our grammar rules do serve a
purpose as it relates to communicating
clearly. And not all grammar rules are
prescriptive. Knowledge of word order,
for example, is very important
for communicating clearly.
And many times is not prescriptive.
Dad be a new pair of shoes bought.
Might be understandable,
but it's a lot less clear than dad
bought me a new pair of shoes yet I'm not
being a grammar prescriptive based.
When I tell you that you should use
this second sentence and not the first.
In order for this to be a prescriptive,
this rule,
both sentences would have to be things
that people actually say and both would
have to communicate the same idea clearly.
But if I were to say Jibo,
he went to the store and you said
actually it's Jim and I went to the store.
That would be an example
of prescriptive ism. Why?
Because of the like are examples of
variations that exist in the language and
both communicate the same idea.
Clearly I'm not at all confused
about who, when, where.
So using proper grammar can be important
as it relates to the exchange of ideas,
but that doesn't mean that
by using improper grammar,
I can't communicate this same idea just
as clearly as long as what I say he is
clearly understood. It makes no
difference how I say tomato, tomato.
If I use whom where I use me and I or
whether or not I use less and fewer
correctly in proper grammar
can be just as important,
just as useful at communicating ideas.
So is using proper grammar
socially important? Yes.
Using proper grammar may not always
be important as it relates to clearly
communicating ideas,
but it is important because
we've made it important.
Kind of like twilight is not
important as it relates to literature.
It's only important because
we made it so yeah, we did.
As a society,
we've made using proper grammar important,
especially in formal situations. If
you misuse their, they're on a resume,
say light too many times in
a job interview or confused,
APEC did effect in an essay,
chances aren't going to be looked down on.
You'll appear uneducated lower
class or even downright stupid.
Even though knowing all the rules of a
standard grammar doesn't necessarily make
you a better communicator.
Unfortunately,
looking down on others for how they use
language is often socially important in
informal situations as well.
No one should have to be judged by
their friends and informal conversation.
No one should be chastised for typing.
See you tonight.
Did a text message without
a period or for misspelling.
A word in the comment section of a
youtube video so long is that misspelling
doesn't cause confusion. Informal
situation should allow people to relax,
be friends,
communicate clearly and openly,
rounds more formal situations often
require a more standardized dialect and
grammar. Why? Just because it
shouldn't be this way, in my opinion.
No. As long as you could
communicate with me clearly,
I don't care how many grammar mistakes
you make besides variation is beautiful
and it makes linguistics
that much more interesting.
So next time you're tempted to look down
on someone because of a grammar mistake,
ask yourself the following, did I clearly
understand what he or she meant? If so,
but it go, here's a, her dialect
may deviate from the standard,
but that's not necessarily a bad thing.
Until next time,
I wonder if capable in her mind
and Kate met Ron ever got together,
or if a hurricane might intercepted.